manchmal schaut er sich die aufnahmen
von seinem toten vater an
damals im krankenhaus innerhalb von 14
tagen ist er an corona in rohan
gestorben vor seinen augen
sie sagten sie wollen die atemgeräte
abschalten ich habe das aber abgelehnt
shanghai lebt gefährlich das offizielle
china will nicht dass er mit
ausländischen journalisten redet seine
geschichte ist eine geschichte die nicht
erzählt werden darf der mythos des
corona triumphs bekommt risse wenn man
ihm zuhört
er will auspacken er wild dass die welt
weiß die behörden in johann
verschleierten den ausbruch des virus
deshalb muss er sein vater sterben
sie haben vieles falsch gemacht
sie haben ein verbrechen begangen eine
verantwortungsbewusste regierung würde
den menschen eine erklärung geben
dies würde sogar ihre glaubwürdigkeit
erhöhen dreimal hat ihn bereits die
polizei verhört er hat das mit seinem
handy aufgenommen
sie bedrohen und überwachen ihn er soll
endlich still sein
was wollen sie von mir fragt er den
beamten kommen sie mit dann sagen wir
ihnen das antwortet er auf der
polizeistation erklären sie ihm er solle
nicht mit ausländischen medien sprechen
wir seien doch alle chinesen dieser satz
machte mich wütend als sie informationen
verschwiegen dachten sie auch nicht
daran dass wir alle chinesen jetzt wo
ich die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft ziehen will
da sagen sie dass wir alle chinesen
seien
seine geschichte beginnt am 16 januar
er fährt mit seinem 70 jährigen vater
nach johann zu einer oberschenkel
operation reine routine
das zu diesem zeitpunkt schon das corona
virus in der stadt wütete wusste er
nicht niemand berichtete offiziell
darüber die stadt wirkte so normal mein
vater wachte von der operation am 22
januar auf sie war eigentlich sehr
erfolgreich gewesen
23 tage später bekam er allerdings am 29
januar erklärte mir der arzt dass er
glaubt dass mein vater am corona virus
erkrankt sei er dokumentierte den
körperlichen verfall seines vaters er
wollte beweise sammeln gegen die die ihn
nicht vor dem virus gewarnt hatten
am ersten februar starb sein vater am
corona ich sagte zu meinem vater dass es
mir leid tut ihn zurück nach wien
gebracht zu haben
aber ich wusste nicht dass dies sein tod
bedeuten würde
am 23 januar riegeln die behörden wo
hahn ab der chinesische staat muss
zugeben dass er ein ernsthaftes problem
hat plötzlich spricht das ganze land vom
corona virus
shanghai entscheidet sich die
stadtregierung von wo hand zur
verantwortung zu ziehen
er zeigt uns seine anklageschrift
erfordert von den behörden
schmerzensgeld und bestattungskosten in
höhe von rund 36.000 euro
die haben bis jetzt die klage abgelehnt
ich fragte den mitarbeiter des gerichts
unter welchen bedingungen er ein
verfahren einleiten würde
er sagte ich sollte doch selber in das
gesetz schauen
ich fragte ihn ob er mir die ablehnung
schriftlich gebe er sagte mündlich
müsste reichen und legte auf er gibt
nicht auf berichtet über sein schicksal
auf den chinesischen twitter rainbow
berichtet über das chaos in den
krankenhäusern in wo hahn und die vielen
leichen
auch die leiche seines vaters lag eine
weile auf dem gang bis sie sie abholten
als die vier männer meinen vater auf
einer bahre wegtrugen folgte ihnen als
sie die tür vom leichenwagen öffneten
sah ich dass bereits ein gelber leichen
sagt drinnen lag präsident schert die
helden seines corona triumphes er ist
für ihn der beweis für die überlegenheit
des chinesischen systems
da passt das verschleiern der behörden
nicht zu den feierlichkeiten
china zeigt lieber mit dem finger auf
das ausland das virus komme jetzt von
dort über importierte lebensmittel oder
einreisende so die staatspropaganda
[Applaus]
verschweigt deshalb seine toten sie
stören
shanghais vater war soldat und ein
überzeugter kommunist in shanghai der
sein leben lang gearbeitet hat und bei
einer immobilienfirma gut verdiente
jetzt hat er seinen job gekündigt um
sich ganz der klage zu widmen
der tod seines vaters fest ihn an seinem
stand verzweifeln ich habe das gefühl
dass viele dinge bei uns gegenwärtig
nicht richtig sind wirklich nicht
richtig sind
ich liebe das land sehr und unterstütze
auch die kommunistische partei
aber ich glaube dass mein wunsch nach
gerechtigkeit nicht mit der
kommunistischen parteien widerspruch
steht
manchmal geht er in den park in dem er
mit seinem vater gesessen hat eine
entschuldigung der verantwortlichen
würde ihm bei seiner trauerarbeit helfen
aber die wollen ihn nur zum schweigen
bringen
meine wut wird immer stärker
sie wächst mit der zeit obwohl es schon
so lange her ist
bevor mein vater ins koma fiel hat er zu
mir einen satz gesagt wenn ich nicht
vergessen werde
mein sohn papa möchte nicht sterben flea
die ärzte an sie sollen mich bitte
retten
ich darf an diesen satz nicht denken
sonst werde ich immer sehr traurig
shanghais schicksal ist das von vielen
zehntausenden die tränen der korona bald
sind aber nicht erwünscht